ضعف الجنسي هو مرض شائع جدا يصيب 25 ل 75%
من الرجال حسب الاعمار
مسببات الضعف الجنسي تنقسم الى اثنين
العوامل النفسيه والعوامل العضويه من
العوامل النفسيه في عندنا البوفيه يعني
الخوف من الفشل اين اهم عامل نفسه باثر
على الحاله اما العوامل العضويه بالدرجه
الاولى عنا مرض السكري ارتفاع ضغط الدم
السمنه او النصاحه همم التدخين ارتفاع
الدهنيات في الدم وانخفاض الهرمونات
الذكريه يا اللي بتصير مع بعض
[موسيقى]
في حاله الضعف الجنسي ينصح استشاره الطبيب
وطبعا ليس الصديق ليش لانه هيدي حالي
مرضيه وممكن تخبي او تكون واجهه لمرض اخطر
واكبر بكثير كيف بيتم التشخيص التشخيص
بيتم طبعا بالاول بفحص سريري دقيق جدا ثم
بفحوصات دم اهمها فحوصات الهرمونات
الذكريه فحوصات السكر فحوصات دهنيه الدم
واهم اهم شيء وهذا ابدا ما مفروض ننسيه هو
تخطيط شرايين القضيب اوكي او اللي بنسميه
نحنا كولر
العلاجات هي متعدده جدا في ابتداء بالحبوب
الى الجلب الى ادويه الحقن فينا نستخدم
الموجات الفوق الصوتيه وفي حال كل هدول
الاجهزه مع جهاز الشفط الفاكم كل هدول ما
مشيوا فينا نلجا بالاخير الى زرع جهاز
الانتصاب او البي 9 اللي هو بيعطينا
النتيجه النهائيه والفعل
[موسيقى]